I changed my mind but I haven't changed
my mind on the principles of what the
charters standing for which is we need
to tackle the deficit and we will tackle
it if that label will tackle the deficit
we're not deficit denies I haven't
changed my mind on that but have changed
my mind on the parliamentary tactics
originally what I said to people was
that look this charter as a political
stunt it's a political trap by George
Osborne is virtually meaningless he
bought himself time and time again he
never meets his targets so this is just
a stunt and let's ridicule it in the
debate and vote vote for it because it's
meaningless vote I went to red car I
went to rick and i met the steel workers
and i had families in tears about what's
happening to them as a result the
government failing to act failing to
intervene and I came back and I realized
as the consequences of government's
failure to invest in infrastructure in
skills the cuts that are going to start
coming now I realize that people
actually are going to suffer badly and
it brought it home to me and I don't
want the Labour Party associated with
this policy